-Good evening, everybody!
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
FBI agents reportedly found
a document while searching
former President Trump's
Mar-A-Lago residence
that detailed a foreign
country's nuclear capabilities.
Even crazier, it was Luxembourg.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Obama returned
today to the White House.
Oh, God, it must have been
like one of those videos
where a dog's owner
returns from the war.
[ As Obama ] "Joe, Joe!
I'm happy to see you, too.
All right, get down, Joe,
get down."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Former Trump
strategist Steve Bannon
is reportedly expected
to turn himself in
to New York state
prosecutors tomorrow
to face a criminal indictment,
and if he's convicted,
he could actually find himself,
for the first time,
sleeping indoors.
[ Laughter ]
During a White House
coronavirus briefing yesterday,
Dr. Anthony Fauci
said the COVID vaccines
will likely become annual,
like flu shots or,
you know, mask-wearing.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Hillary Clinton said
that she started wearing
pantsuits in the '90s
while she was First Lady
after a Brazilian ad agency
used a photo of her wearing
a skirt in a lingerie campaign.
And I don't think I need to tell
you who was the first to notice.
"Hey, Hillary,
you're in a magazine!"
[ Laughter ]
It was reported yesterday that
Pennsylvania Senate candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz once said
in an interview that incest is
"not a big problem if you're
more than a first cousin away."
Replied the interviewer, "My
question was about tax policy."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
16% of Americans said
that they share
and track locations
with their friends and family.
Though, honestly, a lot of them
do now regret that.
[ Laughter ]
"Should we check on where
Uncle Tom is?"
Ay-yi-yi-yi-yi-yi-yi!
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin
returned from the Senate's
August recess yesterday
with his right sling --
right arm in a sling.
But that's also his right sling.
[ Light laughter ]
West Virginia Senat--
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, it's coming off the rails.
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin returned
from the Senate's
August recess yesterday
with his right arm in a sling.
Well, now we know how Biden
got his climate bill passed.
[ Laughter ]
Um, yeah, I think we ordered
this with a neck!
[ Laughter ]
You know, the Biden picture.
Rapper Snoop Dogg has announced
that he's releasing
a new breakfast cereal...
[ Laughter ]
...called Snoop Loops.
And if you thought your kids
fought over the prize before...
[ Laughter ]
"No, it didn't have a prize."
New York's education chancellor,
David Banks, confirmed yesterday
that public school students will
not get snow days this year.
When asked why he said, "'Cause
it's 91 degrees in September."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Target recently issued a recall
for white fudge animal cookies,
because they potentially contain
metal wire.
Even worse, apparently,
they also contain white fudge.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody!